what's going on guys i'm going to show
you a quick video of how
right now i can bill out my house for 10
000
a day and how you can do the exact same
thing so by the end of this video you'll
know
step by step how you can get tax-free
income by
understanding the relationship between
your home and your business so check
this out
so right now i've got my team at my
house so this is my physical house you
can say hey what's up dudes
what's up recording stuff and um
you can use something called the augusta
rule which i'll break down in a couple
seconds
um on the on the screen so you can
understand how it works but the cool
thing is is you can use your home
and generate tax free income for you and
a tax deduction for your business so
you're basically double dipping twice
and it's with assets you already have so
by the end of this video you're going to
have that stuff and you're going to be
able to use it in your own business so
if you're a business owner
listen up watch this video to the end
you're going to love it and in the
meantime click subscribe before i switch
over to the other video
all right welcome back my name is alex
ramose i'm the owner of prestige labs
jim launch
allen and five other portfolio companies
we do about 85 million a year and i have
absolutely nothing to sell you
and so the reason i made this channel is
to help people who
are broke and don't want to be anymore
or people who have lots of money and
want more of it and so that is the
entire point of this
and so let's rock and roll so one of the
important pieces of you know making and
increasing your net worth is making sure
that you keep as much as you possibly
can
while you're generating income and i'm
not saying you should be one of those
people who's obsessed about it because a
lot of times you should put more of your
attention on
your business creating value etc but
there's obviously like
ways that you can decrease your tax drag
right your your tax inefficiencies i
like to call them
a lot of times this is just my
overarching strategy that i would say
with taxes is that
unless you're moving to puerto rico it's
not going to be a silver bullet there's
lots of golden bbs lots of little ways
that you can save here and there
and so right now i want to give you one
of the easiest tax strategies that you
can use if you're a small business owner
pretty much of any kind
like i said earlier in the video it's
called the augusta rule okay
and so i'm gonna try and explain this in
60 seconds it'll probably be a little
bit longer but it will be worth
every second of it all right so if you
have your house
you can rent your house to your business
for employee meetings you can rent your
house to your business for
member events so if you have clients or
customers who are flying into town or
you want to hold an event or a small
mastermind or a workshop
or anything like that at your home you
can lease it to your business
on top of that if you do recording like
i have i've built out i put some capital
expense into my home
which a increase the value of my house
so i get increase in value
two i can use that value to lease to my
business at a higher rate than i
normally would because a professional
studio ran out per day would be five to
ten thousand dollars a day
and it cost me all in to make the studio
uh 30
000 for this room and 50 000 for the
other room which you'll probably see in
other videos
and so on it cost me about 80 000. but
here's the cool part
the industrial states that we can lease
our home to our business for
up to 14 days all right and so whatever
my day rate is that would be fair market
i can multiply that by 14 and i can
write myself a check for that
provided i've used my home for that
period of time now the reason and
when i heard about this i think it was
two or three years ago i went to a
mastermind and a guy was like hey
i'm gonna save everybody the entire cost
of this mastermind in the next five
seconds and i was like
okay i'm taking notes and i took the
notes and i was like that was awesome
and so
in an effort to disseminate information
to the masses for perspective
if you're even making a hundred thousand
dollars a year and you can lease your
home to yourself at a fair market rate
of let's say 500
a day or maybe a thousand dollars a day
that's 14 000 that you can write
yourself as a tax free check and take a
deduction
off of your income from the business all
right easy strategy and if you have a
cpa which hopefully you do just tell
them it's the guest role and what you
plan to do with it and they should be
able to walk you through it from there
and so hope you found video value in
this video hopefully i can make you ten
thousand twenty thousand hundred
thousand dollars tax free
just from watching um and i've got other
videos other strategies about increasing
how much you make growing your business
increasing your net worth and ultimately
getting the freedom you want so uh
check out those videos click subscribe
if you liked it if you didn't like it
you can tell me that i suck and that's
cool i'll
i'll be okay either way all right lots
of love keeping us we'll see you next
video bye